we have an example from the chop
remember the chop I thought the chop was
over chopped Chazz the the occupied zone
in Seattle apparently it's still going
on people are still being killed there
by the anarchists when you replace the
police first of all when you defund the
police you don't just defund the police
it gets replaced with something that's
what we're seeing in LA in the chop when
it gets replaced with is roving gangs
and unbelievably the chop which was
established putative Lee because of
police brutality and they wanted to stop
police brutality while they set up their
own police force and that police force
is now shooting black teenagers and
killing them it's so it's so ironic you
can't say it's funny but it's so darkly
ironic you-you-you almost can't even
react to it a 16 year old fatally shot
in the chop on Monday morning a 14 year
old a child is in critical condition at
the Harborview Medical Center and a
volunteer medic you know they don't have
doctors in the job because it's an
independent country
they've got volunteer medics said that
it was the chopped security forces who
shot the black teenager
the irony is almost too much this person
also described chopped as an active war
zone
well the chop is a little crystal ball
my friends if the chop policy is begin
to be passed in actual cities around the
country in Los Angeles and New York then
we're going to see our cities turn into
active war zones for the near future
it's already happening crime is already
on the rise this is another from a
political perspective good thing for
conservatives to talk about because what
it looks like our cities are headed into
is the 1970s urban decay death mayhem
destruction poverty this led to some
Republicans it most notably Rudy
Giuliani in New York getting elected in
the 90s and cleaning it up because it
doesn't matter what you say your
political affiliation is and your
ideology and when you've got people
dropping like flies around you when you
when you're afraid to leave your
apartment at night you're gonna want a
little bit of law and order
good point to focus on one because it
could save lives before it gets too bad
and two from a political perspective
it's it's one way to exploit what the
left is using as their exploitation
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description